schauen wir auf der kiffen tatsächlich
sie sehen es hier hinter uns Tüten in
Deutschland soll jetzt ganz bald legal
sein die ampelregierung die hat sich das
ja vorgenommen und Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach der will das jetzt
tatsächlich wohl auch umsetzen das führt
dazu dass kleine Mengen Cannabis für
alle aber 18 künftig völlig okay sein
sollen auch die Hanfpflanze zu Hause
straffrei tja und darüber müssen wir
jetzt sprechen 20 Gramm Marihuana für
junge Erwachsene ab 18 Jahre shoppelius
bei uns im Studio dafür dagegen der
Jugendschutz kommt offensichtlich zu
kurz also ist ja erstmal nur ein Entwurf
aus dem Ministerium wir wissen ja noch
nicht ganz genau was draus wird der
Jugendschutz kommt deswegen zu kurz weil
es zwar heißt ab 18 darfst du die 20
Gramm kaufen und das ja dann in
legalisierten Läden und den Apotheken
das ist im Moment der Stand der
Information aber es gibt ja auch noch
den Schwarzmarkt und über den
Schwarzmarkt hast du keine Kontrolle
außerdem werden sie Cannabis rausnehmen
aus dem Betäubungsmitteln das heißt der
Jugendliche unter 18 Jahren der jetzt
irgendeine Menge dabei hat 20 Gramm zum
Beispiel wird straffrei ausgehen das
heißt das Gesetz legalisiert für
Erwachsene darüber kann man sich jetzt
streiten dass der alte Streit zwischen
Alkohol und Cannabis was ist schlimmer
der Jugendschutz aber ist zumindest in
diesem Entwurf noch überhaupt nicht so
entwickelt dass ich den zustimmen würde
und wahrscheinlich viele andere Eltern
in diesem Land auch nicht Karl
Lauterbach hat neulich selbst übers
kiffen gesprochen er hat in dem langen
Interview gesagt er hat dasselbe auch
schon ausprobiert und da hat ganz
schnell die Finger davon gelassen er hat
die Leute bei sich auf dem Dorf
scheitern sehen er hat sie ja dem den
Drogen sich hingeben sehen auf dem Dorf
und hat gesagt davon habe ich mich
sofort distanziert das ist nicht mein
Weg derselbe Minister
ordnet jetzt die Cannabis Freigabe dazu
muss man was ich selten tue ihnen ein
bisschen in Schutz nehmen denn er folgt
dem Koalitionsvertrag zwischen
Gelb-Rot und grün wo das drin steht dass
er das machen muss das heißt er hat
jetzt gar keine andere Wahl was er
damals gesagt hat ist möglicherweise
immer noch seine Meinung und es geht ja
jetzt hier auch darum dass man den
THC-Wert also den Wert dieses dieser
betäubenden Substanz in im Hanf begrenzt
das ist ja ein ehrenwerter Ansatz und da
steht auch neben dem Papier von
Lauterbach drin das würde man ja
deswegen tun und bei bei da wird noch
unterschieden sogar zwischen denen die
zwischen 18 und 21 sind die sollen eine
andere Dosis verabreicht bekommen als
die darüber und so weiter und so fort da
ist von gehirnschädigenden Wirkungen die
Rede sogar in diesem Entwurf das heißt
wir haben es mit einem mit einer
Substanz zu tun die vom Minister selber
und sein Ministerium als äußerst
gefährlich bezeichnet wird das heißt
also diese diese ganze Aktion die wir
hier sehen dieser Entwurf ist äußerst
heikel es gibt ja nun andere Länder zum
Beispiel Holland bestes Beispiel die
Niederlande machen das schon relativ
lange wie Verfahren die da mit dem
Jugendschutz gibt es da Modelle die man
nicht einfach auch für Deutschland schon
übernehmen könnte da scheiden sich ja
die Geister nicht also nieder die
Niederlande wurden immer als glänzendes
Beispiel vorgeführt in den Niederlanden
selbst sieht man das glaube ich sehr
differenziert und da gibt es ja auch
schon jede Menge Bewegungen die
zurückrudern und sagen das ist ein
bisschen aus dem Ruder gelaufen
nach wie nach wie vor gilt das hier
vollkommen fehlt also obwohl dieser
Hinweis enthalten ist auf
Gehirnschädigung vollkommen fehlt welche
Gefahr eigentlich von diesem
Rauschmittel ausgeht es ist übrigens
genauso mit dem Alkohol auch beim
Alkohol sind wir beim Jugendschutz
hinterher der gilt formal aber wir
drücken alle ein Auge zu und die Leute
unter 18 konsumieren Alkohol den sie gar
nicht konsumieren dürfen und auch schon
mit 14 und auch mit 12 also auch da
sollten wir mal reingucken und auch da
sollten wir mal überlegen ob der
Jugendschutz nicht ausgebaut wird das
könnte man bei dieser Gelegenheit mal
mitdiskutieren sagt unser Kolonist
shoppelius danke Dir ganz klare Meinung
zu wenig Achtung für den Jugendschutz
aktuell hier in Deutschland danke dir
danke
[Musik]